alors julie tout va bien j'ai encore
perdu mais caramel vous coûte julie du
devrait organiser
tu leur est organisé un petit peu mieux
tu perds toujours un temps terrible à
chercher tes caramel mou j'étais
justement venu te proposait de faire un
jeu avec les enfants bah évidemment pour
toi y'a pas de problème
tu te manque des ballons c'est facile à
classer vous éclaire heureusement que se
passe-t-il quasi mais il y a un gros
animal tu entrais dans le jardin un gros
animal est sûrs certains
je ne sais pas de quelle espèce il est
mais il pousse des grands moments
terribles ça pourrait être un fauve
alors bien que dans le jardin l'île aux
enfants se mettait un petit peu tu crois
tu n'as pas rêver oh non je me promenais
au fond du jardin
et quand j'ai entendu c'est horrible
grognements et sur la pac de le voir
bouger vite vite couru pour venir vous
prévenir
ça peut être dangereux françois il
faudrait aller voir une aménorrhée des
d'abord je voudrais savoir quel est
l'animal que casimir autant du cje a
entendu des cris d'un gros animal et la
crosse animal mais casimir c'est pas
très précis ça tu n'as pas une idée de
son mouvement
on joue ce n'est pas demander à il
s'appelle peut-être cursus timoléon
bégonias pour fuck les murs parce que je
te demande chaque animal a écrit
différents grâce auquel on reconnaît
l'espèce à laquelle appartient cet
animal ah oui et bien c'est une espèce
de gros animal de gros animal bonne
écoute
julie il ya toujours ton catalogue
sonore à je suis pas arras propos j'ai
retrouvé mes carabine ou attendu tant
mieux dis donc tu as la cassette des
cris d'animaux
mais voilà parfait ça va nous aider à
reconnaître le cri que casimir a entendu
les gens de mer venez avec moi on va
aider casimir
installé dans l'air las alors là ce qui
se passe et enfants tout à l'heure on se
promenait casimir entendu le cri d'une
grosse bête mais il sait pas laquelle
voulait bien l'aider à la reconnaître
bon alors je vous faire passer toute une
série de cris d'animaux
au passage vous les reconnaîtrez et
casimir essaiera de trouver la sienne
d'accord eh bien on y va écoutez mon
premier bruit
vous avez entendu ce cri d'animal à
votre avis qu'est ce que c'est bruno
c'est un âne très bien bon vol un autre
cri d' animal c'est pas celui là écoutez
[Musique]
alors qu'il répond claire un mouton
c'est avant tout c'était sa quasi
méconnu et ça n'aurait pas fait peur
c'est très gentil
bon écoute ça casimir
ça non plus je crois que chez eux nos
amis ont trouvé et il sait dans l'île
aux enfants juliette
qu'est ce que c'est c'est une vache est
une vache qui t'a fait peur kazemi mais
non c'était des cris bien pire
puis à pire que ça écoute allez rire
tiens un chien c'est tous d'accord là
sur dust un chien un gros chien chien un
gros bon ça m'a l'air plutôt d'un petit
chien ça c'était ça non non non écouter
écouter lula ici dans l'île aux enfants
je crois qu'ils ont tous trouvé et chez
eux les enfants aussi sur non alors il
répond nathalie ribout des poules
c'était des poules avec jacques s'était
toujours pas ça alors autre chose
[Musique]
bernard bernardi des pigeons clair clair
un loup alors vous marie-dominique elle
aussi banos vous avez trouvé chez vous
et wavrin don casimir je pense que c'est
par un pigeon qui quitta faits mais n'y
ont en fait une telle frayeur bon alors
je te fais écouter autre chose
qu'est ce que c'est que ça allah y ait
moins de réponse je n'ai passionnait
olivier bernard encore des canards
c'était des canards bon casimir je
continue c'était pas ça non c'était bien
pire
[Musique]
marie-dominique un chat
c'est un chat casimir - marie dominique
a a raison je crois oui mais était-ce
ton animal au nom alors on écoute celui
là claire houry a go rire ayo juliette à
lyon
philippe et ben oui c'était un peu chaud
vous l'aviez pas reconnu les autres bon
encore est loin bruno bernard
bernardines colonne tient encore une
réponse
marie-dominique une chouette c'est pas
ça jeudi la réponse est oui oui on
personne ne sait attend une réponse
une tourterelle nos rêves c'est un
dindon un dindon
dis-moi casimir si je comprends bien
casimir parmi tous ces cris d'animaux
tu n'as pas reconnu celui qui t'a
effrayé tout à l'heure non pas du tout
il faut y aller lentement le chemin
qu'ils amélioreront soyons prudents
je vais mettre en tête c'est par là
alosi halozyme et actions ora l'on passe
devant tous pour tous manque on ne fait
pas de bruit
oh là là ils désigneront ce cri me
paraît bien curieux pour être un cri
d'animal un rocher peur du rebond
j'attends au tiers vous tombez bien je
vais juste de terminer ma sieste
j'espère que j'ai pas ronfler trop fort
c'est un peu demandée au parlement
facteurs le veulent nous n'avons rien
entendu
en tout cas moi j'ai rien entendu et toi
quasiment moi non plus avec moi je les
tiens ona on n'a rien entendu rien dire
rien du tout
[Musique]
il